[Music]  The Voice Blind Auditions continue with  more talented singers and of course more  hilarious coach banter there is  something so classic about her that was  so cool thank you I love your voice I  feel like it has that kind of theatrical  style to it  the coaches absolutely loves 26 year old  hopeful Lily Pissarro a waitress from  Studio City California  [Music]  Blake Gwen and Alicia all turn their  chairs but one coach went the extra mile  your  to put your feelings on you sleep  no surprise here Lily chose Alicia  another standout contestant 16 year old  Savannah Layton uncondition  when in Blake fought over her so badly  Adam Levine couldn't help but call it  like a sporting match with a surprising  move Gwen Stefani taking the little girl  looks like Blake takes the lead but  maybe sleeping on the couch tonight  [Music]  you